comme des poissons dans l'eau sensation
rare et agréable pour ces jeunes de 12 à
20 ans situation de handicap ils ont
récemment pu profiter d'un baptême de
plongée l'eau pour se libérer ça se
passe un institut d'éducation motrice
Charlemagne de Ballan-Miré avec Léa
Turquie
et c'est parti pour le grand saut
une fois dans l'eau visiblement tout va
bien pour tia et ses 5 autres jeunes la
plongée c'est une grande première et dès
la sortie de la piscine les avis sont
unanimes
c'était super cool et si c'est à refaire
je le referai qu'est-ce que tu as
ressenti bien à l'aise
de l'eau c'est vraiment bien j'ai rien à
dire c'est super bien un baptême de
plongée réussie pour ses jeunes de 12 à
20 ans en situation de handicap moteur
tous sont suivis ici à l'Institut
d'éducation motrice Charlemagne de
ballon Miré alors une après-midi comme
celle-ci forcément ça change du
quotidien pour parler on va utiliser nos
mains les gestes l'initiative elle vient
de Salomé monitrice éducatrice et
surtout passionné de plongée on a appris
des jeunes qui ont l'habitude de venir
en activité piscine qui sont à l'aise
dans le haut qui sont aquariatiques et
puis on leur a demandé s'ils étaient
partants et j'ai eu que des c'est
vraiment un dépassement de soi pour les
jeunes parce que mettre la tête sous
l'eau voilà respirer faire confiance à
quelqu'un c'est vraiment du lâcher prise
et c'est quelque chose qu'ils ont
sont pas forcément confrontés se
dépasser découvrir une nouvelle
discipline tout en étant encadré par des
moniteurs expérimentés c'est l'objectif
de la Commission en dissub au sein de la
fédération française d'études de sport
sous-marin c'est vraiment dans un esprit
de découverte ce ne sont que des
mauditsters qui sont déjà qualifiés et
qui dans leur club ont déjà des
plongeurs en situation de handicap et
qui font donc de la plongée en dissuble
c'est que du bonheur derrière les
masques des étoiles plein les yeux voilà
une journée que ces jeunes ne sont pas
prêts d'oublier maintenant ils
n'attendent plus qu'une seule chose
recommencez